hey guys welcome back to smash it a show
we made up because we wanted to burn
some more of défi media's money on
commemorative place that's right Jose
between another writer in this place
this plate represents the x-men
franchise and not just the group movies
Joe all of the solo movies the spin-offs
the whole shebang will they be good
enough to take their spot on our
commemorative hutch or will we break
them with a hammer find out I hope it's
not made of adamantium
I love the x-men from the 90s cartoon
from the comics and from the arcade
games that was my introduction to the
x-men x-men was in a lot of ways
responsible for the big Renaissance that
we're seeing in superhero movies overall
it's a nice neutral franchise it's a
coin flip you get good ones you get bad
ones never quite know what you're gonna
get I saw the very first x-men with my
dad who I'm pretty sure audibly sighed
when I started to go in the opening
credits when you hear the voice over
Patrick Stewart mutation it is the key
to our evolution oh my god finally my
dad was just like why aren't you your
brother he can fix a car the first x-men
I walked out being very excited that I
got to see the x-men on screen but also
feeling a little like oh the Doomsday
Clock we're gonna turn everybody into
mutants is just stupid Sabretooth looks
ridiculous
the only thing I think that would have
made me 100% happy with the first x-men
movie is if at the end of it they turn
to me specifically and say hey Danielle
Radford do you want to be an x-men now
you have mutant powers that's the only
way I would have been happy I remember
the first time I saw x-men I thought wow
that's a lot of leather they're all like
in mugatu's you know fall/winter line
they were just bowing down to the matrix
I didn't mind the black leather thing
particularly because that was the time
that we were in what a real superheroes
wear
motorcycle like jacket leather that
makes sense actually go outside what
would you prefer yellow spandex to me
the characters were so right
I was not disappointed with their
leather biker suits Wolverine Hugh
Jackman this movie gave us Hugh Jackman
I didn't know who Hugh Jackman was
before this so to me it was just they
picked up Wolverine and they threw him
on camera I was really moved by the
relationship between rogue and Wolverine
when they come out does it hurt every
time if it hurts every time stop doing
it every time like really bro really and
thirdly 2004 an angsty time and I'd be
pretty angsty too if people wanted to
chase me down and hunt me down and
eliminate my species that moment where
rogue gets her stripe because she's
touching a thing or something that was
the moment when I was like oh I don't
know about this
Rebecca remained for mistake all the way
I love that line that she said in the
helicopter which he says you know people
like you or the reason I was afraid to
go to school as a child just that one
little line did more for me to know what
Mystique's character was then three
movies worth of Jennifer Lawrence
mystique
this was a year after Phantom Menace and
everyone agreed pretty much that Darth
Maul and Rey Park were the best part of
that movie so to see him again in
another role it was cool he was doing
his Rey Park thing is swinging off mmm
setting up Halle Berry for terrible
lines you know what happens to a toad
when it's struck by lightning
the same thing that happens to
everything else why would what how so
what was the point of that it sounds
like a toe being struck by lightning is
a cliche that we're familiar with but
nobody's ever said that combination of
words in history and the same thing
doesn't happen to everything that's
struck by lightning that's why you put
like a lightning rod in a building
because it can safely absorb the
lightning I applaud them for for getting
the ball rolling but damn that first
ones that one's a rough rewatch x-men -
was everything that I kind of wish the
first expert would be x-men - starts off
right away from me as one of the best
action scenes the Nightcrawler White
House scene is amazing Nightcrawler is
in a white house and he's just
teleporting left and right to get to the
president and you're like damn this is a
way to start a movie
[Music]
it was perfect opening his ability is
really scary but he's also incredibly
only and tragic they do really allow
these characters to be fully formed
that's why I love x-men 2 so much
Wolverine
freaking out on all of the Green Beret
guys Special Forces guys in the
x-mansion is is great
it's Logan finally doing that berserker
barrage inside the kitchen it's one of
the happiest moments ever been in the
theater love seeing Wolverine reach his
full potential beast modes is awesome x2
had obviously the most overt social
commentaries I spend coming out to his
parents as a mutant something I need to
tell you I think they did a great job I
respect their attempt to bring the
social justice aspect that's always been
in the next minutes a little on the nose
sometimes with you know Bobby's mom why
you're on X grinder all the time what
adopted some girls it's very
heavy-handed yeah x-men's real preachy
Bobby dating rogue that's a tough
situation I can't think of any boy
that's gonna be content with just like
holding someone's gloved hand at the
movie theater like it's the 1910s it
must be really hard to be a horny
teenager at Xavier's school if I make
out with you
all of a sudden are you gonna blow up am
I gonna blow up are we gonna go into a
different realm what's happening here
can you just like put a sheet over each
other and just like to turn over the
sheets people do that right last stand
is not a great movie x3 is terrible my
stand was hot garbage
I don't think excellent the last stand
is that bad the best story no no the
best dialogue no it's got stuff in there
shut your mouth that's fine gene came
back and killed Scott because he had to
go be in Superman magneto comes big army
dumb fight wings cut off bridge go bye
that's the plot a major pharmaceutical
company has developed a mutant antibody
they're calling it a killer I actually
think that it's a cool concept like
there is a cure to a part of who you are
as a human being do you take it do you
not they killed off Cyclops at the very
beginning it was shocking they killed
off James Marsden so quickly in that
movie one kiss the kiss of death James
Marsden you were one of our generations
best actors and the x-men franchise did
you wrong my friend they did you're
wrong
what did they call you juggernaut
the juggernaut was just awful there is a
popular meme of
on the juggernaut and they incorporated
into this movie don't you know who I am
of the jungle I'm gonna bring a meme to
life in this movie is it that gonna be
great like no no no you realize the
level of impact this will have on the
mutant community Fraser shouldn't be
beast who's toad
Niles does if this beast has been
awakened within me I don't want
crossover between the x-men verse and
the Frazer verse I thought that's why
you appointed me sir x-men 3 also
introduced horrific Lee cartoonishly
de-aged Patrick Stewart and Ian McKellen
I was like Final Fantasy got a sequel
just the like intense holding in a fart
face that Jean Grey and Professor X are
doing for that entire movie alone it's
just not good so they take this
character in Jean Grey who should be one
of the most fascinating characters do
not give her her due and then kill her
off Phoenix is such an iconic character
and we have all been waiting that's what
we get someone already wrote this they
did it twice they did it in the comics
and in the cartoon just do the thing
they wrote wait why are you doing this
for some reason magneto is in the woods
a lot why was many in the woods I don't
know why magneto is always hanging out
in the woods wouldn't you want to be in
the city where all the metal is sensing
metal around you at all times can be a
heavy burden so perhaps he wants to go
where there's not so much metal maybe
it's just good lurking areas
he doesn't just hang out the woods at
the very end he lifts a bridge
moving the bridge is pretty cool it's
stupid it looks stupid x-men origins
Wolverine bit the dust man's hands down
the worst there's so much that went
wrong with excellent origins Wolverine
I'm gonna give you three one it's trash
the effects are awful people know that
something looks like crap but you don't
want to say anything to anybody because
it's like I don't want to lose my job so
you see something like Wolverines metal
claws and you're like looking good bro
looking good you cheap ass mofos can't
even get a proper CGI explosion behind
this man you can practically see the
outline of the green-screen put an
explosion behind me right now it looks
worse than that the big Wolverine
transformation scene that movie which
everything was built around was like 10
seconds long it was just him and popping
out of the tank and kind of run off into
the woods by everybody and then -
there's way too many characters that
they're just like shoehorning in I mean
the blob and Wraith who was played by
will.i.am in this movie Kayla she's a
mythical girlfriend that is okay with
being impaled by his night terrors it's
just a scratch
oh my god is maverick gonna show up like
are all the real deep dive characters
and the Weapon X lore gonna show up and
then like third what they did with
gambit gambit was really bad cuz that
was back when everyone was trying to
make that Friday Night Lights kid be a
thing he was never gonna be a thing or
Taylor Kitsch I don't know what to tell
you Taylor you're my gambit I don't
think he was that bad as gambit either
you work okay you know what fourth and
what they did with Deadpool can you even
really call whatever Ryan Reynolds is in
that movie Deadpool well you said you
would take the Merc with the mouth and
then take away his mouth what are you
doing what are you doing
clearly you don't even understand the
character and whoa who's with the swords
coming out of his arms why could he
teleport and then
so he had cyclopses I was just this is
too much it is very bad and it should
feel bad and I feel bad for xmin first
class is set in the early 60s and it
kind of covers the origin of the x-men I
always loved going into a different
decade especially the 60 is cool vibes
man it took me back to those sixties era
x-men comics in the look and the feel
and it was a great superhero period
piece it talks about how Charles and
magneto meet they have this idea of
gathering mutants and helping them
understand their powers they nailed the
Xavier magneto relationship as well as
they did in the first two x-men movies
this is a by far the best crafted movie
and it's by far the best as far as
action direction and choreography the
scene where Professor X loses his
ability to walk is heart-rending I love
Michael Fassbender as magneto going back
and kill some Nazis it's one of the ones
that definitely fleshed out the
characters for us you understand magneto
you get where he's coming from he's not
just about chaos he actually has a
purpose it's just funny cause I've been
at the mercy of men just following
orders
never again first class was the thing
that gave us the ability to essentially
reboot and ignore the mistakes and
storytelling with the other ones that we
can move on with cool x-men movies it's
sort of undid the first three x-men
movies because the relationship between
Professor X and mystique is completely
not there but apparently they were like
besties when they were little there are
so many things against first class and I
think it speaks to how good the movie
actually is that it still sort of chugs
through some really really stupid
choices it has that scene where they're
all I hate to see so much where they're
all sitting around coming up with their
x-men names I want to be called mystique
banshee my stage name is angel and now
it's like well now I'm thinking about
how dorky this is you should be
Professor X and you should be Magneto
well there's some cheesy moments sure
did it mess the time I'm up even more of
course I really enjoyed the sequence
where they were recruiting people and
then they tried to hit up Wolverine for
it he was like no freakin way
he's near America until Xavier Goku so
classic Wolvie piss off mate that was a
really fun surprise in in that movie
again it screws up the timeline really
badly but you know what for a really
good middle finger joke I'll let you
wreck your continuity The Wolverine is
the most forgettable one of the x-men
movies it's kind of hard to remember the
Wolverine no one can really quite seem
to remember what exactly happened in the
Wolverine Wolverine goes to Japan I know
that's not the name of it but whatever
it's called
I'm not going to Japan Wolverine goes to
Japan falls in love with the girl and he
has some dreams about Jean Grey there is
something that happens with a lady and
her tongue there's a dude who's trying
to live forever I think he builds like a
machine and there's an explosion I
remember a train I remember an elderly
Japanese man in a large robot sword
there are a lot of katanas
I don't remember this movie at all I
know for a fact that I went to the
theater and I saw The Wolverine I
remember saying that was better than
Wolverine Origins I guess it couldn't
have been too terrible because I
honestly remember next to nothing about
it but you know it also could have been
that good because I remember next to
nothing about it the best x-men film in
my opinion would have to be x-men Days
of Future past this was a pretty great
movie I loved Days of Future past
time-traveling Wolverine fighting
Dinklage and the Sentinels like come in
I love the crossover with the future
x-men and x-men from the past I thought
it was a pretty good balance between old
cast members and new cast members I
liked the 70s
setting of it would you believe me if I
told you I wasn't here for the future
the whole reason this movie exists is to
undo the 57 movies that came before it
and that's about it Quicksilver is just
one of the best action sequences of
those movies the dope is seen in all of
Days of Future past is when Evan Peters
puts on those headphones and he's going
around and he snagging the bullets and
he's doing all of that stuff and it's
like the just coolest that seen his look
in action was sick it's such a memorable
movie moment that they've run it into
the ground since then and now every
x-men movie needs one of those you know
the best part about that scene was how
his music didn't slow down that's how it
would sound if he was really doing that
you have this guy who's presented as a
god basically and then they have to move
heaven and earth to get him out of the
story take it slow because he could
resolve the movie like that if he wanted
to there's a lot in the movie that they
want you to accept without questioning
and I'm really on board they tried to do
all this timeline cleanup and continuity
sweeping they didn't make it clear if
the weird ending with the original ex
cast was just sort of a symbolic
send-off or if that was still continuity
or
how they now connect to x-men first
class okay
so again the timeline doesn't make sense
but if you are applying your primer
logic to the x-men franchise year and
doing it wrong they did so many messy
things before there was so much to erase
I was happy that they did oh god I
finally get to say nice things about
x-men movies Deadpool was a breath of
fresh air I love that movie because it
stands apart so much from the rest of
the movies that I forget it's part of
the x-men franchise we came into that
zero expectations which I could claim
like I knew Deadpool would be a smashing
hit this was the perfect marriage of
character and actor with Ryan Reynolds
Ryan Reynolds loves Deadpool he fought
for it to work they nailed the tone of
the character I'm so sorry
Americans in general we love violence
and comedy I will speak for all
Americans for this a rollicking good
time and you can put that on the DVD box
they nailed the breaking of the fourth
wall spoiler alert
I love the Deadpool head-on acknowledged
Green Lantern please don't make the
supersuit green he can take liberties
with anything he wants he can he can
comment on real-world events the big
house it's funny that I only ever see
two of you it's almost like the studio
couldn't afford another x-man it like
just called out so many tropes like
superhero landing and stuff like that
superhero landing yeah that's really
hard on your knees
I love the dig at the x-men chronology
let's go talk to the professor McAvoy or
Stewart these diamonds okay
using that moment where him and Vanessa
meet back up and underneath it's Hugh
Jackman's face it's taped on which is
such a Deadpool thing and it's gross and
he rips it off it's a case may be happy
to sit on man doesn't everyone want to
love like that where you can look like
just a big uncooked meatball and still
find love with one of the most
attractive women on screen I'm so tired
of the world being at stakes he wants to
get to his hot girlfriend and this guy's
does not like being called Francis it
turned out for an amazing experience
it's so weird what happens when people
who really care about a project get to
make a project Apocalypse sucked
Oh Apocalypse was dumb what the hell
happened man they kept trying to find a
way to shoehorn in younger and younger
actors and then you you pair them with a
villain that looks like Ivan ooze Oscar
Isaac one of the greater actors of our
generation is in a California raisin
outfit I'm old I want a better body
here's a better body
oh no I failed Apocalypse he just kind
of became a generic bad guy than
everyone in the team just sort of blasts
him with some things simultaneously
until he blows up it was in the 80s for
no reason Bryan Singer and his infinite
arrogance puts a joke in the kids come
out of a screening of Return of the Jedi
and they're like well at least we can
all agree the third ones always we're
just trying to take a jab at x-men the
last and homeboy x-men apocalypse is the
third one in your trilogy and this one
sucks lay harder than x-men The Last
Stand also we turn into Jenna is great
they really forced this angle of
mystique inspiring a bunch of mutants
they look up to you Mystique's not
supposed to be a main character in any
of this crap
I think even Jennifer Lawrence didn't
buy that Jennifer Lawrence looks like
she would rather be a pows and be acting
in that movie Jennifer
[Laughter]
she looked at that contract and she was
like how many more of these am i doing
then you shoehorn in the Phoenix stop
with the Dark Phoenix do it right or
don't
do it and and this whole huge movie no
you haven't earned Dark Phoenix put it
down you just blew it Fox
I hope the mouse buys you I hope the
mouse buys you so hard
logan is the one that stands out to me
from the rest of the pack they really
hit it out of the park what logan
there's so much weight and humanity to
this movie and yet it's still so true to
who those characters are it's just a
story about this guy who's taking care
of this older friend and he's got in
charge of this girl I don't think
anybody going into Logan was like this
might be one of the top three comic book
movies of all time huge testament to
Hugh Jackman and what he's able to do
with that performance huge testament to
that script
Daphne Keane was like a revelation that
year delivers this incredible
performance Patrick Stewart he just he
broke your heart as an aging professor
Eck's that can't control his powers
anymore poor professor axe come on can
we leave the dude alone
I loved all that stasis he would he
would shoot out a giant mind beam and
put everybody into it so kind of yeah
there everybody's doing the robot all of
a sudden I mean honestly Logan was
disarming with how truly madly deeply
violent it was right off the bat it was
smart of them to bank on the fact that
they would enjoy r-rated Wolverine movie
Logan's not perfect he has to literally
fight a younger stronger version of
himself it's pretty on the nose I don't
care that the villain is just a CG
younger Hugh Jackman I think it works
Hugh Jackman taking out Hugh Jackman
come on Wolverine is kind of always
portrayed as being this like samurai and
this is how you end an old samurai story
the idea that Wolverine would in his
life sacrificing himself to make sure
that the next generation survives I
thought was a great way for his
character to go out the first trailer
made me cry this movie made me cry x-23
is incredible she made me cry Patrick
Stewart's amazing he made me cry Hugh
Jackman's incredible in this movie he
made me cry the guy from the office is
great in it he made me cry at the end
when they laid him to rest and she's
reciting the lines from the movie that
they watched together oh it wasn't it
was so much crying she takes the cross
and she turns it to an axe and we
to fade out on that image it's a great
visual and it's a great kind of ending
to this character I can't think of a
better way for an artist to go out our
takeaways today hard-r don't do
apocalypse and we treat everything
before Deadpool is phase one they did an
okay job there's just too many of the
x-men when you come into a franchise and
there's 45 characters you can never feel
at home you kind of take it as a given
that they're gonna keep making more
x-men movies at this point Fox I need
you to get it together there's no reason
why the spoof x-men movies are the best
x-men movies despite my best efforts
it's a tie what do we do well I mean
it's sort of boring if we don't break
the plate right right you want to do
both he'll it'll regenerate right do you
have any tape here we go there's some
eyes good as new Joe and who wouldn't
want this beautiful plate proudly on
their commemorative shelf it's a thing
of beauty Jen and then Ben and Joe tell
me when you did Star Wars that you
called this Jabba the Hutt
[Music]
you